et le dossier ukrainien est déjà au
coeur d'une polémique depuis plusieurs
semaines le président russe vladimir
poutine et son homologue américain joe
biden se sont entretenus longuement à ce
sujet le 7 décembre dernier des échanges
par visioconférence que nous détaille
notre correspondante à moscou vera
goffman
de nouveaux détails ont filtré quant à
la rencontre par visioconférence entre
le président russe vladimir poutine et
son homologue américain joe biden les
pourparlers à huis clos entre les deux
chefs d'état du 7 décembre dernier ont
duré presque deux heures est concerné
surtout la situation en ukraine mais
aussi la cybersécurité et le dossier
nucléaire iranien
selon le porte parole du kremlin dmitri
peskov le président américain a menacé
la russie dans un isolement financier en
cas d'incursion militaire en ukraine
écoutez
le président l'a clairement dit au
président américain vous parlez de nos
troupes déployées en russie qui ne
menace personne en même temps vous
parlez alors que vous êtes à 1000
kilomètres de nos territoires
oui en effet hebeisen a dit que si cette
invasion éphémère de l'ukraine avait
lieu apparemment les américains croient
eux-mêmes désormais qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une intox mais de la pure vérité alors
la russie serait isolé financièrement et
ainsi de suite
après le sommet avec son homologue russe
le président américain joe biden a
promis l'envoi de troupes de le temps
vers l'europe de l'est dans les pays
baltes la hongrie la bulgarie et
d'autres jeux baden a cependant souligné
que les états unis n'ont jamais eu
l'intention d'envoyer les troupes
américaines en ukraine